when we last spoke in march you said
that to really get a grip on coronavirus
we need to be testing
virtually everybody four months on how
do you think we're doing
we're doing infinitely better than we
were
we're testing many many more people but
i still don't think we've got the right
strategy in place for what i would call
mass testing
and you know if you think our capacity
is 300 000 tests a day
we're probably only utilizing on our
calculations around about half of that
we'll soon have 500 000 tests a day
capacity
we should be using all of it and that
means extending greatly the numbers of
people who've got access to tests
and using the data and local communities
much more effectively in doing it and
the reason why
i still think we're short of where we
need to be is that i think if you
if you analyze what we know about this
disease now um
and look at the global data the reality
is
we're going to be living with covert 19
we're not going to be eliminating it
what forever well for the foreseeable
future for enough of the future that
means that it's worth putting in place
the containment infrastructure that
allows you to control it
because the the problem is that if you
just look in the last few days
okay you've had surges of cases in
poland australia romania
israel argentina you know several other
countries
so there's a pattern developing which is
that
people go into lock down they ease the
lock down but then
there are significant spikes and we're
still in the summer months
when it's frankly easier to to to deal
with the disease so do you
anticipate a significant spike here as
we leave
lockdown there is a possibility you end
up with a resurgence in the autumn
now it may not happen but you've got to
hope for the best and plan for the worst
and so what we do in the paper we've put
up from the institute to suggest a whole
range of things that you could do now
that would allow you to put in place
that containment
infrastructure one of the other things
that you recommend very
strongly is the use of face coverings
much greater use of face coverings
would you say the government's messaging
on face coverings has been
clear consistent uh no and i think
they're even
even the most ardent supporter of the
government wouldn't say that i mean they
began by saying they weren't necessary
i think we said two or three months ago
it was obvious you were going to go in
the direction of masks
there are certain things that are just
obvious when you look at them and the
evidence on mars by the way is
absolutely clear globally there's no
doubt
they help control the disease if you
look at the countries that have
used masks extensively and not just the
the asian countries where it's more of
the normal culture but take a country
like austria
where they've used masks extensively
there's no doubt they've been able
better to control the disease
and it's all about controlling it
because
if you if you think that you can't
really go back into lockdown
as we were in in say march and april
and i think it's just unrealistic to
think we're going to be able to do that
why not because i think the economic
consequences
even from the lockdown we've had are so
severe if you go
back into another lockdown i mean i'm
already
you know horrified by the potential
economic damage uh even
from the lockdown we've done and the
loss of confidence you go back into
another big lockdown no i think i think
it would be devastating
for the economy so i think put it like
this you can't rule out doing it but
it's going to have to be a terrible
situation
so the likelihood is that you're going
to have
spikes you might have a resurgence and
you're going to have to control it
because you won't be able to go back
into the kind of nuclear option of
lockdown
so if that's the case just prepare now
use the month of august and september to
put in place
the best infrastructure you possibly can
so for example
employers you know already many
employers and a lot of people in the
occupational health management and
companies are helping employers test
their employees
because if you're going back into the
workspace you'd like to know what the
disease status is of the people that
you're working with
we should be making this much more
widely available we should be
coordinating it
you've got to mobilize local communities
you've got to use all the lab capacity
that you have
and then one of the other things that we
say in this report which i think is
hugely important globally
is develop rapid on-the-spot testing not
just for antibody testing
as to whether you've got the disease we
have some of those already but antigen
testing to see whether you have it
if it's so important now to prepare for
uh you know the author in the winter
testing you've spoken a lot about face
coverings too how unhelpful is it when
you see
government ministers going into pressure
mortgage or wagga mama without wearing
the
masks yeah they've got to try and you
know
put it out there as much as possible
communicate by what they do and
there's no look no one likes to wear a
face mask
but it's just you when you look at the
evidence
there really isn't any doubt about it at
all it's a significant
inhibiting factor on the spread of the
disease and therefore you've got to use
it
okay now the long-awaited report into
russia
was uh published this week uh it said
the uk government badly underestimated
the threat from russia and has been
playing catch-up
do you think we've taken our eye off the
ball here
well whether we've taken our eye off the
ball i've just decided not not to put
our eye on it this is an interesting
question but
look going forward what's very clear is
you should build the capability
to and we've got this i mean we're still
with one of the best security services
in the world
you've got to build the capability to
investigate what foreign governments are
trying to do in interfering with our
system
and expose it and the more you expose it
the less it will be effective or the
less it will happen
and we live in a new world today where
cyber security is going to be a massive
massive question for governments
and you know there are governments who
want to weaken the west uh we know
you know basically why they want to do
it you've just got to make sure that
they're
they're all the time constrained you say
there that you weren't sure if the
government took its eye off the ball or
decided not to
to look at the ball it felt like you
were referring perhaps to
the eu referendum to the thought to the
uh suggestion
that no invest effort was made to
investigate whether russia tried to
interfere
in that referendum you can then you can
investigate it without believing that
you know the reason we got breaks look
i'm anti-brexit as you know but i don't
believe we know that don't worry but i
don't believe that's come through the
referendum result
was because of russian interference that
that would be
foolish in my view but but you should
know and and the government should
investigate for the future at any rate
so there should be an investigation you
think
well i think it'd be sensible to
investigate what has happened but really
the most important thing is to create
the capacity
for the future to make sure that that
you know what's going on in your
in your democratic politics because this
this interference and and it's only one
aspect
of cyber security by the way um
this interference is going to be it's
going to be more and more widespread
because the capabilities are much
greater i mean when i was in office
social media was just beginning you know
now you you you've got a whole
industry out there um both that can do
these
types of attacks or campaigns of
disinformation
and those who can protect you against it
although of course on brexit you know
the
government does say it hasn't seen any
evidence of successful interference even
you say that it would be foolish to say
yeah i know
you've got to keep these things in their
context but the fact is you should
protect your country and you should
if someone's interfering with your
democratic process
you want to know about it on brexit uh
briefly do you think we'll do a trade
deal by the end of the year or are we
heading to no deal
i don't know because they obviously
could
land a deal i mean actually we did a
paper last week
showing how you could land a deal but by
the way even the deal we land is going
to be
pretty bad because essentially it's
going to even the deal the government's
wanting
is essentially going to be good for
europe because it's going to allow
easier trade in goods where europe's got
a big surplus with the uk
but it's going to be very inhibiting for
us on the issue of services where we've
got a massive surplus with the eu
we know we know the arguments that have
been rehearsed yeah
many times or on it and do you think
number 10 is relaxed about the prospect
of no deal
no i don't think they'll be relaxed
about it if they're sensible because the
if you've got coronavirus and then you
and all the economic dislocation that's
caused and you put a no deal brexit on
top of that
and then you've now got issues to do
with china and chinese investment
so you'd stack all these things up no i
should imagine they will want to try and
get a deal let's hope they do
on china because it does feel as if that
is one of the biggest foreign policy
issues at the minute you know you've
said that they have serious questions to
ask answer over coronavirus we've seen
some of the human rights things that are
happening in hong kong with the uyghurs
do we need to have a more muscular
relationship with china
well i would put it like this we need to
have a strategy for dealing with china
it's the problem that you have you have
it to a lesser degree with russia you
have it to a much bigger degree with
china
is china is one of effectively
you might say it's one of the two
superpowers of the world today america
and china
and the difference with the old soviet
union days
is that china which is why the cold war
analogy in my view is misleading
is that china is absolutely integrated
into the world economy
so we've received billions and billions
of pounds worth of chinese investment
into our country
we have more i think i'm writing the
same with more chinese students come to
british universities than the whole of
the european union put together
so you have to put up with their
wrongdoing no no you don't have to put
up with your wrongdoings but what
and you have to confront them where it's
necessary to confront them
but you have to do it from a strategic
position where you're also saying to the
chinese
government and the chinese people very
importantly because the chinese
communist party is not the same as the
chinese people
we want to keep ties we want to keep
open for investment that's of a proper
nature and that doesn't put our security
at risk
and we want to make sure that the
cultural exchange that we have for
example
chinese students coming to british
universities
that is maintained so what i'm saying is
don't
you know and our position by the way
will be different from that of america
in some of these respects
because america's america right we we
are going to be in a position therefore
where yes there's a space for
confrontation
there will be a space for competition
there's got to be some space left for
cooperation
you see um you know when you say it's a
kind of a strategic position
i can't help thinking if you know that
sounds like a great thing but if you
strip it back you're effectively asking
to have your cake and eat it
is it really realistic to say look we
could have this you know close
relationship with china
but also call them out where necessary
when if you look you know for example
the chinese government has said
the uk must bear the consequences for
interfering on hong kong
on huawei the chinese ambassador said
you can't have a golden area if you
treat china as the enemy when you've
been prime minister you know it's about
difficult decisions
we can't just have a cake and eat it um
you kind of you quick and eat it but you
can engage with china
in a way that keeps lines of
communication open and
and then in the end it's up to them if
they want to say as a result of
us going with america on the huawei
decision which is essential for us
in the end because you know if america
and our key allies are all lined up on
the one side our security's so linked to
that
of the united states we're so bound to
america in so many different ways around
security questions
that we're bound to go with them on
huawei it's
going to be up to the chinese government
if they then want to say okay in that
case we're not
we're not having chinese investment in
the uk but so far as we're concerned
we should be saying no we're open to
investment provided it's investment that
doesn't put our security at risk
and we're open to ties of cultural
exchange
and for example when it comes to some of
the health questions
climate change questions we will remain
in
you know in in dialogue with you and say
that they continue the dialogue
effectively
and then it's up to them to decide what
they want to do what i'm saying is
we shouldn't be in a position where we
suddenly switch into
hostility that encompasses not just the
activities of the chinese leadership
whether it's on the
uyghurs hong kong uh whatever it is
around security we shouldn't
we shouldn't switch from a position
where we're
confronting on that to saying well in
that case we want to go into a
decoupling where we
were essentially back in a cold war
situation with china because the risks
of that
long term are that you you end up in a
situation where you're alienated not
from the chinese communist party but
from the chinese people
i'm keen to talk to you as well about
scotland
now before the eu referendum happened
you said in my opinion if the uk votes
to leave the eu
scotland will vote to leave the united
kingdom do you still think that's going
to happen
well i think it's a it's a possibility
yeah i mean what what i was saying back
then is a strong possibility
a strong possibility well
it's it's hard to judge look i don't
think it's in the interest of scotland
to leave the uk
um because the ties economic ties
cultural ties
everything is so so strong but of course
brexit particularly if it is a hard
brexit adds an additional dimension
and then i think the the the problem has
been you know my view about scotland is
there's been two problems really
over the last decade um the first
obviously was
after brexit but then even before that
because the labour party went off in a
might view completely the wrong
direction in scotland
um and the conservative party at least
until ruth davidson looked as if they
were nowhere
there was no proper opposition to the
smp now
i think if the labour party as it's
reviving
uh in in england and wales revived also
in scotland that would be
that would be a significant advantage to
preserving the union
do you feel that boris johnson is a
disadvantage to preparing the union if
you look at the latest polling from hugo
for example
67 of scots think the prime minister is
doing badly yeah
it's obviously you know he's not going
to be the person who's going to save the
union in that sense
um but you do need a viable opposition
in scotland and they've not really had
one
and as i say the problem when when the
labour party went off to the left
and then played around with nationalist
sentiment instead of being clearly you
know in the center-left position and
strongly in favor of the union
it lost its purchase um as the
opposition
and then you know other than that period
of time when ruth davidson was leading
the tories there was no one who was
really able to provide a
a coherent alternative to nicolas
sturgeon and the snp
it's pretty clear that you're much more
comfortable with the idea of kierstarma
leading the labour party than jeremy
corbyn
have you talked to him much yeah and i
talk to him from time to time
and as i'm sure he does with the other
former labor leaders and i think he's
done a great job
i mean he's really you know he's made
the labour party competitive again
there's still a long way to go on policy
but you know he's he's made a
a a really impressive start and i think
he's
he's got to a situation where for a lot
of people who had really given up on the
labor party
voters as it were i think they're now
looking at it again much more
sympathetically and they regard him as a
serious figure
you said that there's still a long way
to go on policy what what policies do
you mean
well i think it's i i don't mean that
it's just about
i don't think the last manifesto was
very sensible but i think there's the
big challenge that we're going to have
as a country
coming out of coronavirus and being out
of the european union
is how do we how do we make
how do we make the country's economy
strong for the future
now i believe that the technology
revolution that we're living through
is the single most important thing for
politicians to grapple with
um and i think if britain places cards
right it can become
a significant force in that area but
it's going to require
massive change in the way government
works in the way business works
and whether it's the labour party or
indeed this government
you're going to have to do this in
circumstances where if you're not
careful the coronavirus
brexit and that technology revolution
are going to create an even bigger
social divide and even more inequality
so there's a big challenge and task for
the labour party so i'm just saying it's
going to have to
confront that task and overcome it and
weave these changes into a narrative of
optimism about the future
wealth taxes well it's good to look at
it's got to look at what what you might
raise taxes for
and i think you know there may be
inevitably some increase in tax as a
result of the
big deficit we're going to run but my
experience with
tax when you're in the labour party is
be really careful because by the way the
public out there
aren't you know they're not sitting
there worried as to whether you're going
to raise taxes or not they're probably
worried that you are going to raise
taxes so you're just going to be mindful
of that
concern but secondly
it's also going to mean that you drive
better value
through your public services and through
what government does
because i i don't think it's not
sensible
just to spend the money you know you if
you take our national health service for
example
i mean we can all be great supporters of
it but we should
treat it as if it's a great sort of
living organism and not a kind of
monument where you just
put money into it and don't ask
questions about you know how efficiently
is it operating how can you make changes
for the future how can for example you
embrace technology more fully
so you know there's a there is a
policy agenda out there there's what i
call radical but sensible
and that's where the labour party's got
to go to and i think it's you know that
there's much more talent on the front
bench now
and here is obviously as i say he's he's
a sensible serious guy and
you know we've got the time to get it
right just finally whenever i interview
i always get the sense you just can't
wrench yourself away from politics you
know you're always publishing reports on
coronavirus or
coming up with arguments on brexit and i
just wonder if people think
why after 10 years as prime minister are
you still
trying to be so involved in politics
isn't it time to you know
take some time out go around the golf
course go to the shepherd's hut
um it's not something i want to do look
a lot of people might think
yeah that's exactly what he should do
and stop you know
talking about things but i care about
the country i think we're at a
huge moment of change in the world and
you know the institute that i've built
which has got now almost 300 people
working for it we do work here but we
also do it around the world and
you know it's look it's going to become
i've tried to do something that
previous prime ministers have not done
but
in the future i predict that many more
will try and do because
you leave office you know when you've
still got
a lot of years um of active working life
and when you know your experience you do
learn a lot
and therefore if you're motivated and
you you want to have a sense of purpose
in life then
you know if you if you feel you can make
a contribution you should and then i
i always say to people you don't want to
listen it's very well don't bother with
that
but i'm not i'm not going to be playing
rounds of golf and
you know sitting at home twiddling my
thumbs
that's not going to happen ever